Що найпершим спадає Вам на думку при згадці про Німеччину?
Мабуть, футбол, смажені ковбаски і багато пива!
Що ж, у багатьох кліше є дещиця правди. Але є ще одна річ, яку пов'язують з Німеччиною.
…так реформувати нашу економіку, щоб було менше викидів CO2.
Німеччина вважається передовиком у боротьбі зі змінами клімату. Але чи так це насправді?
Не зовсім. Я розкажу, чому.
Мені в цьому допоможуть…
Історично Німеччина завжди була провідною у змінах клімату.
Це Білл Хейр, дослідник клімату.
У 1980-ті ми започаткували "зелену" політику, системи ресайклінгу, програми енергоощадності.
А це Клаудіа Кемферт, провідна експертка з "зеленої" енергетики.
Якщо це послухати, то ми, німці, - абсолютні суперзірки в захисті клімату.
І так, ми хочемо стати кліматично нейтральними до 2050 року.
Але кліматичні цілі - це поки наміри. Хочемо зробити - ще не означає, що справді зробимо.
На даний момент показники викидів у Німеччині непогані. Але лише завдяки коронавірусним локдаунам.
Як тільки ситуація нормалізується, статистика, вочевидь, буде іншою.
Німеччина ризикує відстати…
Усі вважають, що ми "суперзелені", але в нас є "брудні таємниці". Про першу здогадатися відносно легко…
Що поробиш – ми обожнюємо автомобілі…
І так було завжди. Але більшість автомобілів все ще їздять на дизелі або бензині. Тобто викидають купу парникових газів.
Викиди транспорту в ФРН насправді такі самі, як і 1990 року.
Це наслідок неспроможності політиків останніх 20 років, особливо у сфері транспорту.
Німеччина - країна автомобілебудування. І в нас дуже сильне автомобільне лобі.
Автолобі завжди загравало з найвпливовішими політиками.
Перестати робити ставку на двигуни внутрішнього згоряння та перейти до електромобільності – дорого й ризиковано.
Але це мусить статися, якщо ми хочемо знизити викиди.
Інші країни вже мають конкретні дати, коли двигуни внутрішнього згоряння підуть в небуття.
Франція націлилась на 2040 рік, Великобританія на 2035-ий, Норвегія – на 2025-ий. А що ж Німеччина?
Конкретної заборони у Німеччині не буде. Через автолобі.
Але ми не зовсім застрягли у минулому. Уряд хоче будувати більше зарядних станцій. Держава субсидує купівлю електромобілів.
Щось рухається. От тільки дуже повільно.
Так, окремі виробники, наприклад "Вольксваген", потужно інвестують в електрифікацію своєї модельної ланки.
Але усе це має відбуватися швидше, ніж досі.
Набагато швидше має відбуватися й розбудова екологічного громадського транспорту.
Ми, німці, любимо скаржитися на потяги - вони запізнюються, переповнені чи задорогі.
У 2019 році Німеччина побудувала близько 60 кілометрів нових автомагістралей і проклала лише шість кілометрів нових залізничних колій.
Отож, ми тримаємось за наші автомобілі, через що нам важко з кліматичними цілями. А тепер про другу, ще бруднішу таємницю…
У Німеччині досі працюють близько 100 вугільних електростанцій.
Вони виробляють третину всієї електроенергії і при цьому виділяють величезну кількість СО2.
Хороша новина: ми їх закриємо. Погана новина: до 2038 року.
На думку експертів, це на 8 років запізно для досягнення паризьких кліматичних цілей.
Вгадайте, в якому році підключили до мережі цю електростанцію? Десять років тому? Чи п'ять? Ні. У травні 2020-го.
Це дуже поганий сигнал решті світу. Країни ОЕСР припинять використання вугілля до 2030 року, а Німеччина не приєдналася.
Ми знаємо, що великі країни, що розвиваються, також відмовляться від вугілля до 2040 року.
Важко у цьому переконувати, коли одна з найбагатших країн світу не дотримується узгодженого з науковцями
графіку поступової відмови від вугілля.
Італія хоче вже до 2025 року відмовитись від вугілля. Франція - до 2022 року, там роблять ставку на атомну енергію.
А Швеція зі своїм відносно невеликим населенням вже зараз обходиться без вугілля.
Чому ж Німеччина пасе задніх?
У Західній Німеччині з 1950-их років видобувається багато вугілля.
Це зумовило міцний зв'язок між шахтарями та суспільством, культурну ідентичність, а також політичне лобі.
І тому нам не вдалося поступово відмовитися від вугілля ще раніше.
Підіб'ємо підсумок: Німеччина страждає автомобілеманією.
І Німеччина не може  припинити спалювати вугілля у великих кількостях.
Німеччина не така екологічна, якою її вважають в усьому світі. Нам треба робити набагато більше.
Відмова від вугілля до 2030 року допомогла б розвитку відновлюваної енергетики в Німеччині. Та транспортній галузі.
Ми мусимо почати масштабну транспорту реформу. Залізничний транспорт має ставати набагато привабливішим та дешевшим.
І нам потрібно менше авто, більше екологічних, тобто електромобілів на наших дорогах.
Роботи - непочатий край. Але - до праці, на кону - наша репутація.